est-ce que tu regrettes fière de l'avoir
va traiter de facho plusieurs fois ou
pas du tout il n'y a que ceux magnéto là
non il yad'autres ya ne tient pas le
magnéto islamistes eric naulleau at il
été trop lents avec yassine belattar
alors je te le dis ça y'a pas de manière
trop non mais là là je veux dire il ya
tous les tweets d'eric naulleau il ya
aussi le moment où c'était un petit peu
chaud tous les deux je les ai un voilà
je vous lis voilà les premières tensions
on les a tout est parti d'une question
sur le salaire de jordan bardella te
rappelles géorgie à jim je crois hélas
regarde combien vous toucherez car moi
jordan bardella répondait aux français
ce jeu vous en reviens je touche par
maurice
mélé naulleau
publiés coup sous la ceinture vous serez
bientôt premier ministe de zemmour
laissez moi parler avec jordan il a le
niveau
je vais vous
quelque chose je crois toujours que tu
es de gauche quoi g7
mais
jamais pour le rassemblement national
alors là c'est à 21h06 21h08 deuxième
accrochage entre vous de regarder tu ne
traque de fachos doute une autre et
regarde je te regarde devant des
millions de français de me faire faire
ton coming out devant tout le monde ah
oui je vais dire qu'apache au passage
est toujours triste ça s'est avéré
sa vie à parler des jeux et grotesque
mais comment
dans une autre émission court en
dentelles dans le couloir gauche
et ensuite on va voir qui va partir en
avalant faut pas
se voir des mecs comme toi c'est bon
vous avez vu je redonne la racaille
n'est pas toujours là où il pense
alors
yacine
qu'est ce que tu dis assaillir mais chez
toi tu regrettes tu étais propos d'eric
zemmour eric naulleau pas du pain non
non mais je enfin j'ai un passif à sap a
commencé hier j'ai un passif avec ce
monsieur un moment ça fait 14 ans je
crois qu'il ne vit que de ça de quoi de
ça c'est à dire que à la base ils ont
été créés créer se passait par quelqu'un
qui avait une carrière c'est quelqu'un
jouant laurent ruquier c'est vrai il
s'est réveillé l'a dit je vais prendre
l'extrême droite la droite conservatrice
et la gauche bon le jour où j'ai
commencé à avoir chez ruquier quand même
temps il était d'accord j'ai dit c'est
plus la même émission là on est d'accord
et ensuite l'idée c'est de dire le
bouclier qui l'a de dire je suis de
gauche n'est pas vrai n'est pas vrai oui
mais tu parce que à mon nom peut pas
dire qu'eric naulleau est un facho je te
dis à dire ça ou le poney luxe ici
aujourd'hui je n'accepte que quelqu'un
me traite d'islamistes j'ai plus de
preuves non mais tu eric naulleau est
allé du côté de l'extrême droite que les
gens ont des preuves que j'ai été du
côté de dèche ne m'étais pas rendu les
landes et là c'est quoi un fasciste déjà
pour vous en quoi eric naulleau j'ai lu
dernier me permet de vivre je suis un
chasseur on peut parler oui mais je sais
ce qu'est un fasciste donc un fasciste
donnez moi une seule phrase d'eric
naulleau pourtant moi avec eric on n'est
pas super pote tout le temps mais
donnez-moi une seule phrase d'eric
naulleau qui démontrerait qu'il est
fasciste une seule vous ne l'auriez pas
alors on n'avait pas parce que vous
défendez pas pour poser ma part j'ai dit
une seule phrase merci l'auront une
phrase à part débattre avec des gens qui
ont des
et des positions politiques différentes
une seule phrase d'eric naulleau est non
mais attendez on va recontextualiser ce
qui s'est passé non ils répondent à ma
question une seule phrase d'eric
naulleau qui dirait qu'il est pas qu il
en a pas bon ben alors un terme à nant
donc c'est un fake non mais de dire à
quelqu'un êtes un félin islamistes vous
vous défiler avec le ccf pardon tirer le
drame le style mais je suis là pour nous
cf vous étiez blé où vous sentez vous
les soutenez vous avez fait le droit de
parler métaux pour vous alors oui mais
on retombe toujours un peu on est sur
l'émission d'hier soir c'est
insupportable on sait si vous trouvez
trois jeunes et la tara était trop loin
qu'ils pensent qualité vous lancer vous
avez des ponts cas merci les chéri e
vous pensez oui ben ali mais oui comme
d'habitude mais bon on en est on à cette
discussion avec yacine parce que moi je
pense que quand on quand on traite
quelqu'un de fachos débat ça discrédite
immédiatement la parole et que ça
n'engage absolument pas la discussion
parce qu'en face qu'est-ce qu'on va se
recevoir effet boomerang toi tu es un
islamiste au terrain facho merci au
revoir rideau il ya plus de discussions
possibles valérie non mais tu motion
émotionnel d'hier il ya un producteur
qui est ici moi je suis un petit
producteur tu sais hier je parle à
jordan bardella le patron du front
national j'ai un débat avec lui
eric naulleau coupe la parole pour
défendre bardella